If you're starting a small account right
now, thinking you need to guess right on
10 trades a day just to make lunch
money, you are playing a losing game.
The truth is, the mechanics of a $100
payout are the exact same thing as
making a $5,000 trade. The only thing
that changes is your size. In this
video, I'm going to break down the exact
three-pillar blueprint that took me from
risking $50 a trade, making $100, to
risking now $1,700 per trade, and making
over $5,000 in a single trade, while
only trading a few times a week. We're
going to look at the exact instruments
to use, the math behind scaling, and the
psychological guardrails that are
required to succeed in trading. Now, I
don't just talk about this strategy and
trading in theory. I actually live
stream this exact process and teach it
to over 4,000 current viewers for free
on YouTube every single day during
market hours, so people can watch me
execute live. This isn't just about my
own results, it's about teaching you how
to profitably do this over the long
term. Take a look at this student of
mine right here who applied these exact
principles and completely turned their
trading around and starting seeing
massive consistency. If you want to stop
gambling, look over my shoulder live,
and start scaling, this is the exact
process you need to focus on. Now, let's
jump into pillar one. Pillar one is the
instrument and environment to trade, and
it's crucial to master this first
because picking the wrong asset or
over-leveraging a small account will
wipe you out before you've even had a
chance to learn how to trade. Instead of
fighting the restrictions of standard
stocks or options and the complexity of
those, I and a ton of other traders have
shifted completely to trading futures.
Specifically for small accounts, the MES
and the MNQ. These futures markets track
the broader market index of the Nasdaq
and the S&P 500. Massive markets in the
world with huge liquidity allowing you
to trade these huge markets, but also
start with a small capital. You don't
need a massive bankroll to start. You
can actually start with around $300 is
all it takes to get real skin in the
game. A lot of people ask me what
percentage of their account they should
be risking on a small account like this,
and the reality is forget about
percentages right now. If you try to use
the traditional rulebook of percentages
of risking a couple percentage per
trade, it doesn't really work on a $300
account. Percentage only matters later
in your trading career when you have a
much larger account. Right now, focus on
risking as small as possible to slowly
scale your account. And so when you're
starting out trading futures, you can
risk $20 to $50 per trade on the micro
S&P 500 futures, which is the ticker
symbol of MES. This is why you can start
with about a $300 account. It allows you
to have some cushion when you're risking
that much. Let me show you a quick
example here of years ago where I was
risking about $100 on this trade, little
less, betting that the market was going
to go higher. And so just to zoom
forwards here, once it, you know, you
can see it kind of moves around, jumps
up, and I'm able to close out here at
about $150
risking about $100 initially. And this
is with four contracts actually on the
futures market, which means I could have
traded 1/4 of the size. And so I could
have actually risked, done this exact
same trade here risking about $30 per
trade. So you can really start really,
really small. Now zooming forwards years
later to a trade I took yesterday, I am
still trading the S&P 500 futures here
or the Nasdaq futures and I trade one
contract and you can see based on the
sizing, it's a lot larger. My risk on
this trade is about $700
and then the market moves up and I
slowly manage. I'm not going to go into
too much into my strategy here. That is
for another video and especially if you
tune into my live streams, but
essentially this goes up and I slowly
trail up and I close out for about $900.
I think it was actually close to $1,000
on this trade and that is all done in
about an hour in the morning on average.
And so this is where the scalability
from futures really comes and the
ability to trade the exact same thing
and easily scale up without any
complicated additions. That is a massive
thing about futures that has allowed me
and others to start small, but then
scale up as you are winning with the
strategy. You don't have to adjust
things as you scale up. Now, crucial
thing is you cannot fund an account with
real cash like $300 on day one. I do not
care how eager you are, how confident
you are, you need to start demo trading
to practice your exact setup, what the
platform feels like and just getting
used to the daily routine of things.
Your goal in paper trading isn't to
pretend you're a millionaire trading
huge account sizes, it's to prove that
you can start to consistently make good
decisions, make consistent money on a
demo account, so over time you can shift
to real money. A good suggestion is one
to two months or over 20 trades. And a
good way to start doing this on the
platform I use and I highly recommend
trading on is called NinjaTrader. It's
really good setup for practicing your
trading, getting used to it, and then
building your confidence over time.
Treat that demo account like it's your
last $300. Once the data proves you can
hit your targets without breaking your
rules, you can transfer to a live
account. Now, pillar two is the math of
trading, and it's important because you
don't need to be right all the time to
make consistent money. You do not have
to be perfect to make money trading, and
that is the big misconception for me and
a lot of people when they first start
out. You really just need to ensure that
your average wins are bigger than your
average losses. Trading mathematics
comes down to if you keep your risk at a
certain amount, your profits should
theoretically be larger. So, what does
that really look like? If you're risking
$50 to make $150, you only need to be
right 30% of the time
to break even or make money. So, when
you essentially risk a dollar, you're
looking to make two or three dollars.
The math essentially handles the heavy
lifting. This removes the pressure of
needing to be perfect because at a
one-to-two or one-to-three risk-reward
ratio, you can lose more than half of
your trades. You have visually an ugly
win rate, but you still walk away highly
profitable at the end of the day. A lot
of people come into trading thinking you
want a 90% win rate, and that's not the
case. It is actually flipped. Generally,
the best traders generally have a low
win rate, but they understand how to
manage their risk. They cut their losers
quickly and let their wins run.
Successful trading requires you to have
a bell curve mindset. Think about broad
statistics. You focus on what happens
over a large sample size, not an
individual trade outcome. For example,
let's look at this case study. You take
a trade based on your clean technical
pattern. Your stop loss is set at $30
and your target is $90. Suddenly, a
massive piece of unexpected news, like a
tweet, hits the market and exponentially
moves it in your direction and you walk
away with a $400 win. While that feels
amazing, it is a dangerous trap. It is a
crazy outlier on the far right of the
bell curve that amateur trader looks at
that outlier and gets greedy and expands
their stop loss or changes their profit
target management style because they
think that they want to try and shift
their strategy to catch those outlier
moves. In reality, these happen a very
single-digit percentage of the time.
Outliers derail you. And if you manage
your strategy based on emotional
reactions to one-off events, you destroy
your consistency. My strategy focuses
strictly on that fat part of the bell
curve, that average outcome of what
happens. And to keep your mind grounded
in reality during this process, I highly
recommend to implement a cash-out rule.
When you make a profit at the end of the
week or the month, withdraw a portion of
it. Move it out of your brokerage to
your checking account. Make that money
tangible. You need to start making the
digital numbers on your screen feel
real, physical money. If you don't
physically touch the money you make,
your brain will treat it like a video
game currency, you'll get sloppy with
your size, and you'll inevitably give it
all back up. This is what casinos do
with why they transfer your money to
plain chips. They want to remove that
reality of that it's tangible, real
money. Now, pillar three is behavioral
guardrails. And this pillar is the most
important thing in trading because the
best strategy in the world is completely
worthless if you don't have hard
boundaries and rules to stop your
emotions from self-destructing
your trading. You shouldn't be staring
at charts all day. That is number one.
The highest volume in the US markets is
the first 60 to 90 minutes in the day of
the market open. So, for me, that means
my trading day happens between 9:30 a.m.
and 11:00 a.m. Eastern time. I show up
20 minutes before the market opens. I
map out my key levels and what I'm
looking for, set an idea of what I want
to see that day, and then wait for my
setup to show up. I don't look to react
to what the market does. I look to see
if the market fits my checklist. Because
what's actually important is learning to
not fit the market, but have it fit you.
This is where your edge is. Your edge is
your strategy, not learning how to
perfectly react and predict every single
move in the market. not consistent over
time. Trust me, I've tried it. And the
whole reason why being done after an
hour or two is you start to become
fatigued. You get decision fatigue over
time, and you're more likely to make a
bad decision, chase because of FOMO, and
not be able to stop yourself making an
impulsive decision, which will derail
your day or your week. That's why you
want a specific time that you're going
to trade planned into your day. And so,
let's go through some important
guardrails. One, you need a specific
amount of time you're going to trade
every day, and you don't break that.
Once it hits, let's say 11:00 a.m.
Eastern or 10:30 a.m. Eastern, unless
you're in a trade, you're done for the
day. Another big one is set a hard
stop-loss or profit limit. No matter how
much, if you are up on the day a certain
amount, you call it, because the idea is
you don't want to chase and get greedy
and continue trading. I literally just
had someone in my live stream chat this
morning say they were up over a thousand
dollars and they kept trading because
they got greedy and they gave half of it
back up. Instead of if they just took
that win and left for the day, they
would have had more money. And they knew
that they FOMO'd and chased out of
greed. And on the flip side, you want to
have a fixed stop loss that You can have
this set up in Ninja Trader in your
trading platform to cut you out from
trading if you hit a certain loss for
the day. Or what I usually do is I
usually just take one trade a day. If it
wins or loses, I'm done. To me, this
allows me because I've noticed over time
the best trade that I find is usually
the first one that I enter. After that,
it's usually downhill from there. And
then another one is do not set a daily
profit target or a daily trade target
because this will force you to take
trades on a bad day or try and revenge
trade if you are behind and losing
money. Do not go into a trading day
having a goal of I want to make a
hundred dollars today or I want to make
five hundred dollars today because
that's going to force you to focus on
the money, focus on the individual trade
outcome, and derail the bigger picture
process of showing up to trading and
just executing your strategy. When it
comes to trading, you want to be
extremely methodical. Pilots use a
checklist before every single takeoff.
You need a pre-flight routine as well. I
have a checklist that I use every single
morning that you can actually see on my
live stream. Before I click buy or sell,
I go down the list and check off every
single thing. Is the market aligned? Is
it big picture trend of what I'm looking
for? And then I go down my list of Is it
a reversal level? Am I seeing a
confirmation of a reversal? What this
does is it aligns me with what I'm
looking for every single time and helps
it be a clean, methodical, repeatable
setup. Instead of just blindly having it
in my head and starting to roughly
follow it because it allows you to if
you don't have that rigidity to really
just kind of be all over the place.
Because when you're starting out and
just trading in general, you want to be
focused on becoming a process focused
machine. The money will naturally follow
when you prove you can manage risk.
Because scaling from $20 of risk to
where I am now like $1,700 of risk uses
the exact same process, the exact same
charts, the exact same pattern, exact
same checklist. Because I've focused on
process of trading, not the actual money
of trading. The money in trading comes
from when you scale up. And initially,
you need to build a foundation. And so,
the first part of that process is
starting to paper trade. I've used
NinjaTrader for over 5 years now. I
highly recommend getting it. You can get
it via this QR code or the link in the
description. And then if you want to
learn more about futures, check out this
video right here and make sure to come
to my live streams every single trading
morning at 9:00 a.m. Eastern Standard
Time to see what this looks like in real
time and grow with me and all the other
traders there.